[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم اجرت قوى سياسيه يمنيه مشاورات
مع الحوثيين في صنعاء لبحث تشكيل مجلس
رئاسي لسد الفراغ في السلطه وياتي ذلك بعد
انتهاء مهله حددها الحوثيون للتوصل الى
اتفاق نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في
محورين ما هي ضمانات نجاح اي اتفاق على
تشكيل مجلس الرئاسي المؤقت في اليمن في
تخفيف حده الصراع على
السلطه وما هي المالات المحتمله سياسيا
وامنيا لهذا الاخفاق المحتمل في التوصل
الى تسويه مرضيه لجميع الاطراف في
[موسيقى]
اليمن في مناخ ملبد بالخلافات يرعى
المبعوث الاممي جمال بن عمر منذ ايام
مشاورات بين قوى سياسيه يمنيه والحوثيين
للتوصل الى اتفاق لسد الفراغ في السلطه
بعد استقاله رئيسي الجمهوريه والحكومه
ويبدو ان معظم الاحزاب وافقت مبدئيا على
مقترحا لتشكيل مجلس رئاسي وان بتخريج
وشروط مختلفه وتبقى تفاصيل هذا المقترح
وضمانات نجاح اي اتفاق بشانه محل جدل في
وقت احتجت فيه قوى سياسيه وثوريه على
اجراء مشاورات مع الحوثيين في ظل هيمنتهم
الراهنه على مفاصل الدوله
اليمنيه لا يزال الاحتقان الامني والسياسي
مخيما على اليمن بعد نحو اسبوعين من
استقاله الرئيس عبد ربو منصور هادي
وحكومته والفراغ الدستوري في البلاد
المترتب على ذلك تتحدث الانباء عن اقتراب
قوه سياسيه من اتفاق على تشكيل مجلس رئاسي
ينهي ذلك الفراغ الدستوري وجدد المبعوث
الدولي لليمن جمال بن عمر دعوته لكل
الاطراف للعمل على تحقيق حل سريع ينهي
الازمه لكن بقراءه وضع اليمن الراهن لا
تبدو الامور بهذه البساطه حزب المؤتمر
الشعبي العام وافق مبدئيا على المجلس
الرئاسي شريطه اعتماده من البرلمان وبينما
انسحب التنظيم الناصري من المشاورات تحفظ
التجمع اليمني للاصلاح ولا يزال منخرطا في
مشاورات وطرح الحزب الاشتراكي موافقه
مشروطه باجراءات لتعزيز الثقه بين الاطراف
وقاطع حزب الرشاد السلفي المحادثات منذ
انطلاقها طارحا جدليه جدوى اجرائها في ظل
السيطره والقبضه الامنيه المحكمه لمسلحي
جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين على مختلف
مواقع الدوله السياديه بالعاصمه صنعاء
وبمحافظة
تنفيذ تهديداتهم بالتحرك منفردين لسد
الفراغ الدستوري لكن صحيح ايضا ان لكل
الاطراف السياسيه والقبليه في اليمن
رؤيتها فيما يتعلق بتفاصيل المرحله
القادمه وصحيح ايضا ان وجود الحوثيين
المسلح بالعاصمه والمحافظات يظل عقبه
كاداء تعيق اي اتفاق خاصه اذا اصرت
الجماعه على دمج عناصرها المسلحه المقدره
بنحو 20,00 في مؤسسات الدوله العسكريه
والامنيه
الثابت ان اليمن يعيش اوضاعا سياسيه
وامنيه بالغه التعقيد وتوضع علامات
استفهام كثيره داخل اليمن وخارجها امام
شكل ومقالات اي اتفاق يولد في غمره هذه
الاوضاع وفي الذهن مالات مخرجات مؤتمر
الحوار واتفاق السلم والشراكه الذين تعهدت
مختلف الاطياف بمرجع تهما في شان الدوله
اليمنيه معنا في هذه الحلقه من صنعاء
الباحث السياسي ماجد المدحجي والناشط
السياسي في جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين
حسين البخيتي ومعنا من اسطنبول الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي ياسين التميمي نرحب
بضيوفنا جميعا لو بدانا بالسيد حسين
البخيتي يعني هل لديكم امال كبيره فيما
يتعلق بالتوصل الى اتفاق حول هذا المجلس
الرئاسي بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والصلاه
والسلام على سيدنا محمد نعم اخي العزيز
هناك المفاوضات ما زالت جاريه رغم ان هناك
بعض التلكؤ او الرفض من قبل حزب الاصلاح
والناصري لكن نتمنى بان هناك اصبح شبه
اتفاق وان هناك ايضا مرونه في التعامل مع
الموضوع من قبل حزب الاصلاح فنتمنى في
الساعات القادمه ان لم يكن غدا ان يتوصلوا
الى اتفاق لتشكيل مجلس رئاسي يعني هل هل
انتم ربما احرص الناس على ذلك لانه هو
الذي يمكن ان يكون مخرج لكم من ازمه م قبل
ان تكون ازمه
البلاد لا لا هو هو سيكون مخرج من ازمه
البلاد لاننا نريد دائما التوافق وليس
مخرج لازمه لازمه الانصار الله في البلاد
لانه اذا لم يتم التوافق على ذلك فان
اللجان الثوريه ما زالت هي ستكون هي
الشرعيه
القائمه لعمل قرارات واتخاذ اجراءات ل لمل
هذا الفراغ الذي الي نتج عن استقاله
الرئيس هادي وحكومه بحاح ولكنهم الى الان
ما زالوا اللجان الثوري ما زالت مرنه
لاعطاء الوقت رغم انها لديها خطه وسوف
تتخذ القرارات اللازمه عندما يصل عندما
تصل هذه المفاوضات الى طريق مسدود نعم على
ذكر هذا الفراغ اسال السيد ياسين التميمي
في اسطنبول هناك من المحللين والكتاب
يقولون الان الكل يبحث في موضوع الفراغ في
حين ان ليس هو الفراغ المشكل لا في رئاسه
الجمهوريه ولا في رئاسه الحكومه المشكل
الحقيقي هو سيطره الحوثيين على مفاصل
الدوله ا بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم بالتاكيد
ما قلته صحيحا 100% المشكله في اليمن ليست
في الفراغ الدستوري الذي خلفته استقاله
الرئيس والحكومه لان الرئيس والحكومه فقد
اصلا القدره على التصرف وعلى ادا مهمهمه
دستوريه بشكل كامل وبالتالي فان المشكله
الحقيقيه اليوم تكمن في هذا السيف المسلط
على اليمن الممثل في الحركه الحوثيه
المسلحه التي يسميها زميلنا في البرنامج
حسين لجان ثوريه هذه اللجان الثوريه اليوم
التي يهدد بها ويضعها سيف مسلط على القوى
السياسيه هذه هي اسس المشكله اليوم هذه
التي تهدد ليس فقط
مستقبل التسويه السياسيه وانما يعني تلامس
قضايا في غايه الحساسيه تلاس تلامس مستقبل
اليمن السياسي هويه اليمن السياسيه هذه
الجماعه تقود اليمن بقوه الى الى النظام
او الى الى صيغه النظام التي تخفيه وهو
النظام الامامي هذا النظام
الذي يعني يكتسب يعني كل مواصفات النظام
الشمولي
ال العميق في في في في في الظلاميه هذا هو
الهدف الحقيقي الذي تخفيه هذه الجماعه
المسلحه وتراوح في اظهاره في هذه المرحله
اليمن اليوم مهدد في كيانه الاجتماعي في
كيانه السياسي في
كيانه في كيان الدوله في في جغرافيته في
الجيوسياسيه التي يتمتع بها اليوم اليمن
الان على مشارف الانهيار والسبب هذه
السلطه التي منحت لتنظيم مسلح للاسف
الشديد من قبل قوى دوليه واقليميه شعرت
اليوم بانها ارتكبت خطا فظيعا في
ح مع ذلك كل القوى وهنا اسال السيد ماجد
المدحجي كل القوى
بشكل او باخر تشارك في هذه المشاورات
والسيد جمال بن عمر ايضا يشرف عليها
ويشارك فيها اليس في النهايه كل هذه القوى
جاءت للمربع الذي اراده الحوثيون وخضعوا
للمنطق الذي فرضته على الحياه السياسيه في
البلاد مرحبا بالبدايه واضح انه هناك
السمه الاساسيه للاطراف السياسيه المشاركه
في مسار التفاوض الحالي هو الاذعان اذا صح
التعبير هذا الاكراه السياسي والمسلح اللي
تمارسه جماعه الحوثي على الفضاء العام
واضح انه احد اول نتائجه هو هذا الاذعان
الغير مفهوم من قبل اطراف العمليه
السياسيه بمعظمها باستثناء يعني الان موقف
التنظيم الوحدوي الشعبي الناصري الذي خرج
من هذا المسار وسابقا عليه حزب الرشاد
الذي رفض دون ذلك يذهب الجميع الى مسار
سياسي تحكم معادله القوه وفرض الهيمنه على
الغطاء العام بارتداد ذلك العنيف على
الفضاء الوطني على المجتمع على علاقه
المكونات الوطنيه بعضها اذا كنا نلوم
دائما او نقوم بانه جماعه الحوثي غير
حساسه لتداعيات ما تقوم به على الوطن على
المجتمع فهو بالاق در ايضا النظر الى
مسؤوليه الاطراف السياسيه التي تشارك وهنا
هي ليست فقط حساسه بل متواطئه مع عدم
مسؤوليه جماعه الحوثي في خصوصا في
المقالات التي سيذهب لها تفاوض سياسي واضح
انه كل ما سينتجه سينتجه المزيد من اداء
من الازمات حتى الصيغه الدستوريه او
الصيغه السياسيه للحل المقترحه هي لن تقوم
شيء سوى باعاده تنويه باعاده جدوله الازمه
على طاوله العمل على مدى الفتره القادمه
بينما النظر الى الاسباب التي ادت الى
هكذا وضع قائم عليها الحوثين بغلبه السلاح
لم يتم طرحها ابدا وباستثناء هذه القول
الخجول من قبل الحزب الاشتراكي بتطبيع
الاجواء فواضح انه الامر يذهب الى الى هذه
الصفقه الرديئ والسيئه بين جميع الاطراف
نعم ولكن مع ذلك سيد حسين البخيتي
الذين ايدوا بشكل او باخر وان بتحفظات
فيما يتعلق بالمجلس الرئاسي لديهم بعض
الشروط او بعض المواصفات لنجاح هذه الخطه
ان يسحب الحوثيون سلاحهم ان ان ان يكفوا
عن قمع المظاهرات ان يكفوا عن التدخل في
وسائل الاعلام وقمع الصحفيين واعتقالهم
واقتحام المؤسسات هل جماعه انصار الله
مستعده لدفع هذا الثمن مقابل الوصول الى
مجلس رئاسي يتفق عليه
الجميع لا في في البدايه يجب التوافق على
المجلس الرئاسي اما بخصوص ما ذكرته
بالسلاح
وانتشار مقاتلين انصار الله
فهذه كانت هناك فقره في مؤتمر الحوار
الوطني تنص على ان يتم سحب السلاح من جميع
الاطراف والاحزاب والقوه في اليمن والتي
من ضمنها حزب بال الاصلاح والمؤتمر الشعبي
العام لذلك مخرجات الحوار هي شرعيه موجوده
ولكن من كيف سيتم تنفيذها هذه المشكله من
بعد انتهاء الحوار كانت هناك حكومه
باسند اسمحلي الان السلاح السلاح المطروح
بقوه هو سلاح انصار الله يعني حتى وان كان
الشعب اليمني كله مسلح تقريبا هذه معروفه
لكن الان السلاح المستعمل في قمع
المظاهرات في السيطره على المؤسسات في
اقتحام البنايات المباني الرسميه وهو سلاح
انصار
الله ن نعم لا السلاح لدى انصار الله سلاح
لدى حزب الاصلاح وفي مارب سلاح لدى
الاطراف كلها سلاح سلاح سلاح انصار الله
هو الفعل سلاح انصار الله هو الفاعل يعني
سلاح انصار الله هو الفاعل والشغال كما
يقال يعني نعم نعم لا اقوللك مثل ما مثل
ما كان سلاح علي محسن الاحمر وسلاح حزب
الاصلاح بعد ثوره 2011 يمنع انصار الله
ويمنع بعض الاحزاب الاخرى من المشاركه فان
فان سلاح انصار الله سوف يتم استخدامه
لانهم يريدون التوافق ويريدون مشاركه جميع
الاحزاب وسلاح انصار الله وسلاح اللجان
الشعبيه هو مرتبط بشكل اساسي مع مخرجات
مؤتمر الحوار التي تنص على سحب جميع
الاسلحه من جميع القوى فلمتر الشعبي العام
وعلي عبد الله صالح نعرف اسلحه كثيره في
مناطقهم وايضا حزب الاصلاح لذلك سيتم
تنفيذ مخرجات الحوار ولكن ذلك سيكون عن
طريق هذا المجلس الرئاسي الذي سيكون فيه
القرار بالتوافق ولن يكون هناك شخص الرئيس
هو من يتخذ القرارات المصيريه للبلاد فهذا
هو الحل الاول الذي نبدا به لخروج اليمن
من هذه الازمه ولكن هذا المجلس الرئاسي
اذا ما راى النور سيد ياسين التميمي الا
يشكل في
النهايه ايجاد مخرج لماز الذي وصل اليه
الحوثيون ووصلت اليه البلاد اكثر مما هو
مخرج ل تسويه سياسيه حقيقيه في
البلاد وهذا هذا يذكرنا باتفاق السلم
والشراكه الذي تحول الى اتفاق للتسليم ا
بالكامل للجماعه الحوثيه المسلحه هذا نوع
من التغطيه على الجرائم التي ترتكبها هذه
العصابه المسلحه وقد عرفنا في 21 سبتمبر
ايلول الماضي كيف انه ثبت بالدليل القاطع
ان اقتحام صنعاء و وتدمير الجامعات
والمدارس وال اقتحام البيوت واعتقال
الناشطين السياسيين كان فعلا مدبرا ترعاه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وبالتالي كان
اتفاق السلم والشركه تغطيه واضحه واحدث
قطعا مع المرجعيات الاساسيه للتسويه
السياسيه وبالتالي فان اي اتفاق اليوم
ياتي عبر صيغه المجلس الرئاسي هو حاله من
حاله القطع ايضا مع مرجعيات التسويه
السياسيه التي تحمي التسويه السياسيه في
اليمن وبالتالي تشرعن للاعمال الاجراميه
التي تقوم بها ه هذه العصابه المسلحه
اليوم وته يهدد من خلاله حاضر مستقبل
اليمن للاسف الشديد يتضح من كلام زميلنا
في البرنامج اليوم ان الجماعه الحوثيه لا
تريد قرارا مستقلا هي تريد ان تهيمن على
مستقبل اليمن على حاضر ومستقبل اليمن عبر
صيغه المجلس الرئاسي الذي سيكون الحوثيون
هم اقوى طرف فيه ولكن اسمح لي ما يعني
اسمح لي ماذا ماذا لو الاطراف الاخرى وهنا
اسال السيد ماجد المدحجي ماذا لو الاطراف
الاخرى استطاعت ان تقتلع من جماعه انصار
الله مجموعه من التنازلات بين قوس
منها سحب السلاح والخروج من صنعاء والكف
عن هذا الاستقواء بالسلاح في هذه الحاله
سيصبح المجلس الرئاسي مكسب للبلد اكثر منه
مكسب لاي طرف
كان بدايه يجب النظر قبل الذهاب الى اي
مسر تفاوضي يجب النظر في الاسباب الفعليه
التي ادت الى هكذا وضع وتحديدا والتعامل
مع الاستحداث المسلحه في في المدن التي
قامت بها جماعه الحوثيين وليس اخرها ما
حدث في 192 يناير هذا مستوى من التعقيد لا
يمت بصله ايضا للتعقيدات المتصله بعدين
بما هي الخيارات التي يجب النظر فيها
لتجاوز الاسما هل الخيار المجلس الرئاسي
يشكل حلا نافذا وفعالا بعيدا عن كونه
مصلحه للحوثيين هل هو مصلحه لليمنيين حتى
لو تقاطع مع كونه مصلحه للحوثيين هنا يطرح
سؤال اساسي لانه واضح انه هذا الصيغه من
الحل رغم انها ايضا تقول بانه سيتم نقل
مستويات الازمه الى المستوى الاعلى في
اداره البلد و هنا ستكون هذا المجلس
الرئاسي يحظى بموقف اقليمي يعبر عن نفسه
ضدا على هذا المجلس الذي يراه خارجا على
المبادره التي رعاتها دول الخليج اخيرا
اليوم وزير الخارجيه الكويتي يعبر عن موقف
امين عام المجلس عبر عن موقف بالتالي ما
هو السياق التي ستذهب لها اليمن في هكذا
خيار حتى لو انتزعت بعض الاطراف بعض
التنازلات الاجرائيه من جماعه الحوثي ما
هو مستقبل هكذا حل سياسي في قذ في هذا
الحقل من الاشواك بالمعنى الاقليمي
والداخلي ناهيك عن كون ما هي الاسماء التي
ستاتي لهكذا مجلس لانه دون وجود شخصيه
جنوبيه وازنه في حال رفض الرئيس هذه
البقاء في موقعه عبر الصيغه الجديده هذه
او فما هي الشخصيه الجنوبيه الوزنه التي
تستطيع ان تردم الفجوه التي سيخلفها هذه
اتفقنا او اختلفنا على اداؤه لانه هناك
تداعي جنوبي غير محسوب واضح في النظر الى
التفاوضات السياسيه القائمه بالحاله لا
يجب الحديث عن تفاوض على كل يعني بعد اذنك
هو على كل يعني طالب
ن يعني بعد اذنك يعني طالما الان
المشاورات مستمره ولا شيء مضمون فيما
يتعلق
ب النتيجه في النهايه نريد ان نعرف بعد
الفاصل ما هي المالات السياسيه والامنيه
لاي اخفاق محتمل ربما في التوصل الى تسويه
مرضيه لجميع الاطراف في المفاوضات او
المباحثات الجاريه حاليا في اليمن لنا
عوده الى هذا المحور بعد فاصل نرجو ان
تبقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها سبل الخروج من
ازمه فراغ السلطه في اليمن والمقالات
المحتمله لاخفاء القوى السياسيه في التوصل
الاتفاق سيد حسين البخيتي قبل قليل اشرت
مره اخرى انه اذا لم نصل الى اتفاق فال
اللجان الثوريه كما تسمى وهي الاسم الحركي
لجماعه الحوثي هذه اللجان مستعده للتصدي
وح ححمل مسؤوليه المرحله ومسك السلطه يعني
باختصار شديد هل جماعه انصار الله قادره
ومستعده الاحتمال من هذا
القبيل في الاول هو ليس اسم حركي لان
اللجان الشعبيه هي من جميع
مكونات الشعب على كل يعني لا احد لا احد
يصدق لا احد يصدق هذا سيد البخيتي يعني
انت من حقك تقولها بس بس لا احد يصدق على
كل مش هذه القضيه تفضل نعم انا من حقي
اقوله وانت وان وانت من حقك ان لا تصدق
والبعض من حقه ان يصدقها نعم لذلك اي اي
قرارات سوف تتخذ ستتخذ بشكل تدريجي و
وسيعتمد فيها لانه يجب ان نعرف ان الاطراف
التي في الحكومه
كهذ والمؤتمر والاصلاح ليسهم كل اليمن
فهناك لديك الحراك الجنوبي هناك شباب ثوره
2014 هناك انصار الله وهم يعني لديهم
تواجد كبير فلذلك اذا تم في اذا لم تنجح
المفاوضات واتخذت هناك اجراء
لملء الفراغ الذي دائما ما يلام انصار
الله عليه
فانه ستقوم على قاعده ان يكون هناك مشاركه
من الاطراف الرافضه لهذا الفراغ الذي ممكن
ان يؤدي لليمن الى انهيار يريدون ان
يلوموا به انصار الله و ولكن يعني اسمحلي
من اسمحلي من من مستعد ان اسمح لي من
مستعد ان يشارككم في سلطه هي اشبه بكره
نار لا احد يريد ان ان يلعب بها بين يديه
يعني اذا اذا ما فشلت الامور ستكونون انتم
المسؤولين الوحيدين وعليكم تحمل تبعات ذلك
من من مستعد ان ينتحر معكم لا
احد لس ي يجب يجب ان ان تعرف انه لسنا
لسنا المسؤولين المسؤول هو من وقع
الاتفاقات وقدم الاستقاله حتى الحكومه
ترفض مزاوله اعمالها كتصرف الاعمال يعني
انت تتحدث انت تتحدث الان اسمح لي انت
تتحدث عن استقاله الرئيس واستقاله الحكومه
وكانها سبب الازمه هي نتيجه للازمه هي
بسبب سيطره الحوثيين وصلنا الى ما وصلنا
اليه وليست هي سبب
الازمه لا لا انت يجب ان تعرف ما هي سبب
سيطره اللجان عندما بدات المعارك وتم
الاعتداء على المتظاهرين وقتل العشرات
منهم وتم الاعتداء على الاهالي في قريه
القابل من قبل علي محسن هذا ما ادى الى
دخول انصار الله وطرد علي محسن والسيطره
على الفرقه اولى مدرع ولم ولم يريدوا
السيطره على صنعاء
ولكن الجيش اليمني والاجهزه الامنيه في
محاوله منها لنشر الرعب والفوضى في صنعاء
قامت بسحب جميع نقاطها من كافه انحاء
صنعاء فاضطرت اللجان الشعبيه ان تسيطر
لتحافظ على صنعاء من النهب والسلب نعم بغض
النظر عن عن هذه الروايه اس يعني بغض
النظر عن هذه الروايه التي هي لي روايه
طبعا هي محل نقاش للاسف لا يمكن ان ان
نقوض فيه اكثر من ذلك لكن اذا ما سارت
الامور بعكس
ما تريده جماعه انصار الله سيد ياسين
التميمي ما هي المالات التي يمكن ان تراها
اذا لم يقع التوصل الى اتفاق برضا
الجميع اعتقد ان الخيارات محدوده جدا امام
الجماعه الحوثيه المسلحه الان لكن قد تلجا
الى خلط الاوراق و والوصول بالبلد الى
مرحله التصفير يعني مرحله اللا دوله وفي
هذه الحاله سيكون جميع الاطراف في حل من
امرهم ايضا قد ربما هذه الجماعه تلجا
استنادا الى قوه السلاح التي تمتلكه في
العاصمه صنعاء الى التخل تلص من الشركاء
السياسيين باي شكل في هذه الحاله سيكون
هذا كارثه سياسيه كبيره لانها ستطلق
العنان لكل المكونات السياسيه ل تشكيلتها
المختلفه للشباب للاقاليم الاخرى لكي
تتحرك في مواجهه هذه العصابه العصابه
ستكون حجتها انها تريد ان تملا الفراغ
الدستوري لكن في نهايه المطاف هي تسيطر
على النظام لدوافع جهويه وطائفه والجميع
لن يسكتوا وبالتالي سيقاتلون من اجل
استعاده الدوله واعتقد ان منطق الذي يقاتل
من اجل استعاده الدوله ستكون قوى ايضا
الاقدام على هذه الخطوه بغض النظر عن
المعادلات الاقليميه والدوليه اعتقد ستكون
ايضا كارثه لا اعتقد الحوثيين كان
بامكانهم بعد محاصره الرئيس وتقديم
استقالته ان يضعوا ايديهم على السلطه
وانتهى الامر ولكن لانهم اصلا كلفوا بمهمه
منذ يناير 2014 وحتى هذه اللحظه وجدوا في
هذه المره ان المجتمع الدولي غير مستعد
والاقليمي ايضا لتغطيه نشاطهم لانه كان
نشاطا يتجاوز كل الاعتبارات وبالتالي
اوقفوا هذه الجماعه عند حدها ومنعوها من
الاعلان عن صيغ مجلس وعملوا كل ما بوسعهم
لكي ياتي على الاقل هذا المجلس استنادا
الى توافق كل القوى السياسيه فتكون تغطيه
على الاقل قائمه على الاجماع الوطني لكن
في حال قام الحوثيون بمل الفراغ على
طريقتهم بمعنى السطو على السلطه يعني و في
هذه الحاله بيكون سطوا جهويا طائفيا
مفضوحا في هذه الحاله سيتحرك المجتمع
اليمني بكامله وسيدخل اليمنيون في صراع لح
لا نستطيع ان نتهم
بمقالاته يعني بعد اذنك انت اشرت اشرت
اشرت الى يعني عفوا اشرت الى المعادلات
الاقليميه والدوليه هنا اسال السيد ماجد
المدحجي جمال بن عمر الذي البعض ينتقده
بشده لانه يبدو وكانه ي شرعا لاي تطور
يجري على الارض ويريد ان ان يلقى له غطاء
بعد ان تتم الامور و وتحسم الامور بالقوه
على كل بغض النظر عن ذلك السيد جمال بن
عمر التقى بسفراء فرنسا الولايات المتحده
روسيا الاتحاديه ايران وهذه اشاره مهمه
والولايات وال بريطانيا هل تعتقد بان هذه
الدول ستكون حريصه على ان لا تصل اليمن
الى اخفاق في المباحثات الجاريه
حاليا
ا لدى الكثير من الاطراف رغبه في البقاء
اليمن على الاقل في وضعه الراهن يعني على
الاقل ضمن حدود الحافه الحرقه التي هي
عليها اليمن وعدم تداور الامور باتجاهها
صرع اوسع لكن هل هذا خيار يمكن ضمانه من
قبل هذه الاطراف خصوصا انه عوامل تحريك
اللعبه هي عوامل محليه لكن مالتها اللاحقه
في حال مزيد من التفجر السياسي وخصوصا في
حال قبض الحوثيين على السلطه بشكل مطلق
بعيدا على اطراف المسير العمليه السياسيه
سيكون مالتها متفجره واسعه وبالتالي سيصبح
موقف هذه الاطراف رهينا بعدين بمجموعه
مصالحها المستحدثه واليوميه الان هناك
هناك تعبيرات واضحه عن طبيعه الادوار
الاقليميه والدوليه التي بدات تتجسد بناء
على الازمه الحاليه هناك القو هناك الحديث
عن قوه فرنسيه لحمايه الاستثمار الفرنسي
الضخم في بلحاف او في شبوه استثمار الغاز
هناك دور الاقليم وتحديدا السعوديه وغيرها
فيما يخص تحديدا الوضع الجنوبي او في
المنطقه الشرقيه هناك كثير من الاطراف
التي ايران في علاقت بالحوثيين بالتالي
هذا سيجر محاور الصراع الاقليميه وتعقيدات
علاقه هذه الدول التي كانت الى وقت قريب
تحاول ان تقدم اليمن كنموذج لنجاح التعاون
الاقليمي والدولي هذا الشكل من التعقيدات
متصل بفشل المسار السياسي ولا يكفي
الاطمئنان الى كون هؤلاء يمال او يقولون
ال انهم يدعمون اي خيار للتسويه كما عبر
عنه بيان العشر بالاضافه الى الاربعه
الدول الاخرى في الذي صدر اخيرا التعقيدات
تتسارع وتغير الدول يتسارع بناء على ايقاع
المحركات الداخليه وما ستؤول اليه
التفاوضات بين الاطراف وكيف سيقرر
الحوثيين بصير اليمن باعتبارهم القوه
الراجحه الان بناء على غلبه السلاح في
تحديد خطوط المستقبل اليمني القادم شكرا
جزيلا لك سيد ماجد المدحجي الباحث السياسي
اليمني كنت معنا من صنعاء ومن صنعاء ايضا
كان معنا الناشط السياسي في جماعه انصار
الله الحوثيين حسين البخيتي وكان معنا
ايضا من اسطنبول الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
ياسين التميمي شكرا لهم جميعا وبهذا
مشاهدينا الكرام نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه
هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر غدا
باذن الله نلتقي فيما وراء خبر جديد
استودعكم
[موسيقى]
الله